WE ALWAYS LIKE TO
CHECK IN WITH OUR FRIEND
DERANGED BILLIONARY JOHN
HODGMAN.
USUALLY JOHN WILL GIVE US SOME
IDEA ABOUT WHY HE'S DROPPING BY.
BUT THIS TIME HE JUST SAID HE
HAD A BIG ANNOUNCEMENT.
SO I GUESS WELCOME TO THE SHOW
JOHN HODGMAN.
JOHN HODGMAN, EVERYBODY!
NICE TO SEE YOU, JOHN. GOOD TO
SEE YOU.
THANKS FOR STOPPING BY AND
JOINING US.
>> CAN YOU STOP TALKING NOW? IS
THE CAMERA ON ME?
>> Jon: YES.
>> GOOD, THANK YOU.
JON, THE REASON I CALLED YOU
HERE TODAY --
>> Jon: WELL, I'M HERE EVERY
DAY.
IT'S MY SHOW. SO I'M HERE-- IT'S
NOT LIKE YOU --
>> PLEASE, JON, THIS IS HARD
ENOUGH WITHOUT YOUR BLUBBERING.
I HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY.
I HAVE BEEN APPEARING ON THIS
SHOW FOR ALMOST 10 YEARS NOW.
THIS SHOW DOESN'T DESERVE AN
EVEN SLIGHTLY RESTLESS DERANGED
BILLIONAIRE --
>> Jon: WHAT?
>> AND SO I'M MOVING ON.
( AUDIENCE REACTS )
>> Jon: REALLY?
>> THE POINT IS, I'M RETIRING TO
AN EXCLUSIVE GATED COMMUNITY.
>> Jon: WOW! YOU'RE GOING TO
FLORIDA?
>> NO, JON, AN EXCLUSIVE GATED
COMMUNITY ON MARS.
>> Jon: MARS, THE PLANET MARS?
>> YEAH.
TECHNICALLY IT'S CALLED
SUMMERWINE LINKS AT THE
HELLAS IMPACT CRATER.
BUT WE JUST CALL IT THE COLONY,
STAR WIPE.
AH, THAT WAS GOOD.
>> Jon: YEAH, USUALLY WHEN
YOU DO A STAR LIFE IT'S TO GO TO
A DIFFERENT SHOT.
>> PICKY, PICKY.
YOU DIRECT ONE MOVIE AND ALL OF
A SUDDEN YOU'RE
FRANCOIS TRUFFAUT.
YOU KNOW, TRUFFAUT LOVED STAR
WIPES, BY THE WAY, LOVED THEM.
THE POINT IS, BOTHERING YOU,
JON, WAS THE ONLY REASON I STUCK
AROUND IN THIS INCREASINGLY
SOCIALIST CESSPOOL OF A PLANET.
AND NOW WITH YOU'RE LEAVING IT'S
TIME FOR ME TO REJOIN MY KIND.
>> Jon: WHAT THE -- STAR WIPE!
WHAT? ARE YOU SAYING
YOU'RE A MARTIAN?
>> WHAT? NO WE GOT RID OF THE
MARTIANS -- THEY WERE
TANKING OUR PROPERTY VALUES.
I'M JUST A VERY WEALTHY HUMAN
WHO SUMMERS OFF PLANET.
JON, WE .01%-ERS HAVE HAD A
SPACE COLONY FOR YEARS.
>> Jon: WHY?
>> WELL, MARS IS A BILLIONAIRE'S
PARADISE-- NO TAXES NO,
REGULATIONS, NO UNIONS.
PLUS THERE'S INFINITE ROOM FOR
OUR LAVISH ORGIES.
WE STILL HAVE TO WEAR OUR
SPACESUITS, THOUGH.
SAFETY FIRST.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> Jon: SO YOUR ORGIES ARE JUST
MOSTLY JUST DRY HUMPING
IN SPACE?
>> WE CALL IT THUMPING CROTCH
PLATES.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Jon: JOHN, HOW DOES THIS
SOCIETY MADE UP OF ONLY
BILLIONAIRES FUNCTION.
BECAUSE DON'T YOU NEED NON-RICH
PEOPLE TO PROVIDE YOU BASIC
SERVICES? YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO DO IT YOURSELVES
-- BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE, DANCE
FOR YOUR AMUSEMENT.
>> YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. OF
COURSE.
WHY DO YOU THINK WE BILLIONAIRES
ARE SO OBSESSED WITH COMMERCIAL
SPACE TRAVEL.
>> AMAZON FOUNDER JEFF BEZOS'S
COMPANY BLUE ORIGIN
SAYS IT'S READY TO START
SUBORBITAL TEST FLIGHTS
THIS YEAR.
>> BRANSON'S IN ON IT. ELON MUSK
IS IN ON IT.
>> THIS IS BRAGGING RIGHTS FOR
PEOPLE WHO CAN SPEND A QUARTER
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES OF WEIGHTLESSNESS.
>> Jon: SO YOU'RE SAYING
THAT YOUR-- ON MARS, YOUR
MIGRANT WORKERS--
>> ARE LOWLY MILLIONAIRES, YES.
BUT, SOMEONE HAS TO UNCLOG OUR
SPACE TOILETS AND CLEAN OUR
CROTCH PLATES
>> Jon: THAT MAKES SENSE.
>> WELL, I COULD TALK ABOUT
CROTCH PLATES ALL NIGHT BUT I'VE
GOT TO GET GOING.
SO PUT ON MY HELMET.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT.
( APPLAUSE )
ENJOY YOUR ROCKET TRIP.
>> ROCKET TRIP, JON?
YOU THINK I'M GOING COACH.
THESE DAYS THE BEST PEOPLE ALL
TRAVEL BY MYSTERIOUS COSMIC
MONOLITH.
OH, THERE IT IS NOW.
FAREWELL, EARTHLINGS.
BAAAAM!
BAAAUM.
I AM THE STAR CHILD.
OH, MY BODY'S WEIRD.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> Jon: THAT'S THE WEIRDEST
( BLEEP ) THING I'VE EVER SEEN.
FAREWELL, STAR CHILD, JOHN
HODGMAN.
I GUESS NOW YOU BELONG TO THE
AGES.
>> HI, I FORGOT SOMETHING.
( LAUGHTER )
I'M LEAVING BEHIND HUNDREDS OF
EMPTY INVESTMENT CONDOS, YOU
KNOW, TO MAKE SURE THAT
NEW YORK IS FOREVER UNAFFORDABLE
FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS.
>> Jon: OKAY.
>> SO COULD YOU WATER MY PLANTS?
>> Jon: SURE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jon: BY THE WAY, THERE WAS A
LIGHT SHOW, YOU TURN INTO A
BABY. WHAT THE HELL WAS THAT?
>> YEAH, WOULDN'T THINK
ABOUT IT TOO HARD, JON.
IT'S VERY DEEP.
ANYWAY, GOOD-BYE!
OH, AND THAT WHOLE THING ABOUT
BILLIONAIRES BEING ESSENTIAL JOB
CREATORS, YEP, WE MADE THAT UP.
GOOD NIGHT.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
YOU KNOW, SO, THE POORS WOULDN'T
KILL US.
THE ONLY THING THAT REALLY
TRICKLED DOWN WAS
BULL ( BLEEP ). GOOD-BYE!
>> Jon: JOHN HODGMAN,
EVERYBODY.